paul zinke danke is
german for thank you and you're about to
thank me for introducing you to this
fella paul danke you're welcome
hi thank you mitzi it's great to be at
the club
finally um i'm paul danke thank you for
having me
um it is nice so nice to be here with
all of you
i miss people so much i miss people in
my home i miss having house guests
and i used to hate having house guests
now i
i would give anything to have someone
stay over at my house
and i'm i'm the worst kind of host too
because i think
i'm a good host and i'm
i'm really not you know i'm a i'm a real
mikasa sukasa kind of a guy you're at my
house whatever you want
take it you're thirsty get yourself a
drink you want a snack
it's yours you need a jacket i got a
bunch all right
um my sister was over and she wanted to
go get herself a little drink of water
so you go help yourself
you go right on out you go right on the
head and then you know she comes back
out and i'm like
and that's the cup you think we drink
out of nobody drinks out of that cup
nobody that's not a drinking cup all
right
you took the quarter cup that's where we
store our quarters
in case we got to go watch the duvet
which honestly we've not been able to
find that cup for quite some time
therefore the duvet is dirty and i'm
afraid you may have swallowed
one or two quarters let us know if you
start to feel sick later i
she's i love i care i worry about her
i worry and i the thing is as a host i
think that i'm chill
but i'm i'm just not you know i think
i'm a laid back guy and then
i head into the bathroom after someone
takes a shower and i'm like
and that's the side you think we open
the shower curtain to
what are no nobody opens the shower
curtain to that side
you think we you think we step over the
toilet
you think we step over the toilet to get
out of the
out of the shower wake up why do you
think the bath mats
on the other side you think oh the
shower curtain needs a bath mat
it doesn't that's for your feet we think
we step into the toilet wake up
wake up what world do you live in
she was staying with us and um uh my
sister was hungry and she wanted some
toast and i said have an english muffin
we keep english muffins in the house for
the guests
for myself mostly but also because
everybody deserves a premium toast
experience and
she goes in she has an english muffin
and she says what do i do
with the extra english muffins well just
throw them in a ziploc bag
no worries let's keep the freshness you
know top-notch
and then as as you do the
smell of english muffin lingers wafting
through the house
sure i decided i'm ready to now have an
english muffin myself
and i go down and i find the muffins in
the ziploc bag
as requested but she did take him out of
the box first
so the box is sticking out of the top of
the ziploc bag
like the titanic just before it finally
took the big sink
down to the briny deep and all of the
freshness was gone
i'm not eating it stale english muffin
off your rocker
i would give anything to have anyone
stay with me now i miss it so much and
when this is all over if you think that
you're gonna come over and stay at my
house
and sleep on an air mattress you're off
your rocker
okay you're in the master bedroom oh
yeah i'm changing the sheets
i'm giving you the good covers yes i
will be sleeping at the foot of the bed
but i'm a sweet little puppy boy what do
you want from me i gotta tuck in and
keep your tootsies
i gotta keep your tootsies dry keep them
warm that's what i do
for you the guests
thanks so much everybody thanks mitzi
for having me uh you know i used to work
with dorothy club
it means a lot to be here in the online
platform thanks so much
i'm paul danke and i will see you all
when it's safe thanks so much
laugh at your screen
[Applause]
thanks for coming to bananamores